this episode is brought to you by tab
for a cause a free Chrome extension that
helps you raise money for causes you
care about just by browsing the web
every time you open a new tab they make
a donation to a charity of your choice
and right now they're working with the
n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund if
you'd like to help install the free
extension using the link below for years
now the topic of questionable statues
has divided the United States and other
countries around the world in the wake
of the 2017 Charlottesville white
supremacist rally and subsequent murder
of Heather Haier there came a new wave
of voices calling for the removal of
Confederate statues and other perceived
hate symbols in the three years since
and especially since the beginning of
2020 the discourse surrounding statues
and monuments to historical figures has
escalated in this episode we're going to
talk about the reasoning for tearing
down these symbols and the notion of
revisionist history Confederate soldiers
and officers frank rizzo king leopold ii
slave auction blocks the confederate
battle flag Cecil Rhodes Christopher
Columbus in the aftermath of the murder
of George Floyd countless statues
monuments and symbols around the world
especially in the US have become targets
of protests vandalism and calls for
action statues honoring the Confederacy
have long been viewed with distaste by
many Americans and are understandably
one of the most common targets for
removal but the intensity of the recent
wave of protests has also inspired a
more critical look at other historical
figures a statue of the late Frank Rizzo
a notorious bigot and past mayor and
Police Commissioner of Philadelphia was
taken down on June 2nd statues of
Columbus have been decapitated or dumped
in bodies of water the statue of
prominent British imperialist Cecil
Rhodes has faced intense criticism from
Oxford students in recent days and in a
more surprising turn of events NASCAR
has banned the Confederate flag from its
races as a fun side note this new rule
sparked one NASCAR driver racer le to
resign and protest his resignation is
fitting because he and the Confederacy
share the exact same stats zero wins but
jokes aside the NASCAR announcement and
the new wave of willingness by state
officials to reconsider the existence of
races statues and symbols has been met
with a huge outpouring of support but as
with anything there is a vocal subset of
people opposing the removal of these
symbols and their argument is always the
same by taking down these icons we're
erasing or rewriting history and you
know what I'm willing to give those
people one thing understanding history
is very important it gives us context
through which we can understand present
situations what they don't get quite
right though is the role the monuments
play in understanding history so what is
a monument at its core it's a physical
manifestation of a time period person or
idea that some group wants to
immortalize they represent things we
have determined to be deserving of Honor
these monuments are often erected while
the figures being depicted are still
alive or are only recently passed
because of this monuments are often a
product of their time or a product of
intense emotion surrounding a prominent
figure who through the passage of time
is eventually determined not to be
worthy of honor after all other
monuments like many of the 700 plus
Confederate statues in the US are
erected decades or even over a century
after the events they depict the most
telling fact about these Confederate
statues is that the vast majority of
them were put up in the Jim Crow era of
segregation
whereas earlier Confederate monuments
were mostly memorials to dead soldiers
those put up later almost always
depicted the leaders of the Confederacy
Jefferson Davis General Lee or Jackson
and they weren't placed in cemeteries
but in public squares and in front of
government buildings they were intended
to instill certain values into those who
looked at them and the desired values
were deeply racist after the backlash of
the civil rights era the establishment
of new Confederate monuments tapered off
but the spread of other forms of hateful
icons did not in 1956 the state of
Georgia redesigned its flag to include
the Confederate battle flag and in 1962
South Carolina placed a confederate flag
above its Capitol building
eventually the initial 700 statues
became over 1500 instances of
Confederate imagery installed in public
spaces some people in the American South
see the Confederate flag and the
associated monuments as nothing more
than vague symbols of appreciation for
what they consider to be their heritage
and a war in which neither side was
clearly in the wrong but when it comes
to images with sinister backgrounds this
case is about as clear as it gets
defenders of the Confederacy are quick
to say that the Civil War wasn't about
slavery it was about states rights to
which the obvious response should be a
state's right to do what the answer is
own slaves and the architects of the
Confederacy weren't exactly shy about
saying so one such man Alexander Stevens
said the cornerstone of the Confederate
States of America
upon the great truth that the Negro is
not equal to the white man that slavery
subordination to the superior race is
his natural and normal condition most of
the wealthiest people in America before
the Civil War were slave owners and they
wanted to protect their interests so
they launched a campaign to trick poor
white farmers into feeling superior to
and afraid of black slaves long story
short they started a war to protect
their perceived right to own human
beings and exploit them for massive
profits that is the history of the
Confederacy the Confederate battle flag
is no more a harmless symbol of southern
heritage than the swastika is German
heritage post-war Germany is a useful
comparison here in the aftermath of
Hitler's defeat swastika flags and
banners were torn down and torched
before the cities had even been cleared
of debris Nazi icons were destroyed and
banned from being displayed in public of
course there were Germans who still
identified with the Fallen regime and
their bigoted views didn't vanish
overnight the removal of Nazi ikons was
a necessary first step towards saying
this was not okay but it still took time
for the country to heal learn from its
mistakes and become the nation it is
today a nation far less tolerant of
bigotry than the United States but where
the Germans have come to grips with
their responsibility for that horrific
period of their past the United States
still faces that challenge as long as
the monuments valorising Confederate
leaders remain in place we are showing
the world that our nation has not
accepted its culpability in the evil of
slavery tearing down the statues is a
necessary first step this is where the
claims of revisionist history come in
let's talk about that the rallying cry
revisionist history is an accusation of
rewriting the facts of what happened in
the past
taking down a statue is not rewriting
history erecting statues honoring
slave-owning traitors to the country
decades after those traders lost their
war for the explicit purpose of
validating superiority over black people
is revisionist history taking the
statues down is not erasing history
either books are a thing that exists the
knowledge of the events of the Civil War
isn't just going to disappear from our
collective consciousness because we
remove a statue put up in 1950 but
here's the more important thing the
people who claim that taking down
statues is rewriting history don't even
know the history to begin with take
Christopher Columbus Columbus for
whatever reason has become one of the
most important historical figures for
white America
yet if you ask those people what he
accomplished they might maybe be able to
tell you that in 1492 he sailed the
ocean blue some will say he discovered
North America which is very wrong
he never set foot in North America he
landed in South America and explored
some of the South and Central American
coasts others will claim he proved the
earth was round wrong again historians
agree that there is ZERO doubt that the
educated of Columbus his time understood
the earth was round that had been
established as early as the sixth
century BCE but neither of these is the
reason Columbus statues have been the
target of recent protests the most
important thing that many people don't
know about Christopher Columbus is that
he was a monster as governor and Viceroy
of the first Spanish colony in the
Americas Columbus ruled with an iron
fist
when a man was caught stealing corn
Columbus had his nose and ears cut off
before selling him into slavery when a
woman dared suggest he was of low birth
one of Christopher's brothers had her
tongue cut out and then paraded her
naked through the colony Columbus
praised his brother for his actions
Columbus was also a rabid slaver on one
of his voyages Columbus and the
Spaniards rounded up 1500 men women and
children put them in pens and selected
those best suited for manual labor they
loaded them onto ships and sailed back
to Spain to sell the natives into
slavery 200 of them died on the voyage
back Columbus would later write let us
in the name of the Holy Trinity go on
sending all the slaves that can be sold
but selling human beings was among the
least of his crimes believing there was
gold in Haiti Columbus forced every
native over the age of 14 to collect and
bring him a certain amount of gold every
month those who failed would have their
hands cut off and were tied up until
they bled to death some 10,000 people
were murdered this way the problem was
there was basically no gold to be found
there and when the slaves attempted to
escape their fate they were hunted down
and killed Columbus and his men were
ruthless the testimony of one priest
reported that the Spaniards thought
nothing of knifing Indians by tens and
twenties and of cutting slices off them
to test the sharpness of their blades he
went on to say two of these so-called
Christians met two Indian boys one day
each carrying a parrot they took the
parrots and for fun beheaded the boys
the Spaniards tortured the native
inhabitants for sport decapitating them
raiding their villages for sex slaves
some as young as nine years old throwing
them into boiling soap raping the women
even
feeding live children to their hunting
dogs and all with the blessing of
Christopher Columbus and before you
accuse me of getting all this from some
revisionist history book let me share
with you where much of this information
comes from after complaints of
Columbus's brutality reached the Spanish
courts Queen Isabella and King Ferdinand
ordered him shackled and returned to
Spain in the year 1500 he was replaced
by Francisco de Bobadilla who was also
tasked with writing a report documenting
Columbus's atrocities the resulting
report was 48 pages long the opponents
of bringing down the Columbus statues
are quick to yell revisionist history
but have clearly demonstrated they don't
know his actual history themselves and
they can't claim that all of this is
slander from years later because it was
documented at the time all the way back
in 1500 so really those defending
Columbus and whitewashing his story are
the ones actually engaging in
revisionism funny how that works but
let's take this a bit further a lot of
people get revisionist history and the
practice of historiography mixed up
revisionist history is whitewashing past
atrocities or simply making things up
historiography is the study of the
methods of historians in developing a
written history it's essentially an
analysis of past written histories this
discipline has existed since the 5th
century BCE while written histories are
fascinating and incredibly valuable for
their insights into past events history
ography provides the critical lens of
reevaluating how those histories are
written were they written by a
conquering army were they written in a
time period where certain practices were
deemed acceptable or unacceptable
applying modern standards of evaluation
to historical events doesn't change
history but it helps us gain perspective
on how things have changed and how
individual historians may have shaped
the narrative of their histories taking
a critical look at figures like
Christopher Columbus or robert e lee is
not rewriting the past but rather
reckoning with the legacy of the past
and how historical symbols appear to
those whose ancestors were affected
taking down the statues and symbols of
hateful racist or tyrannical figures
doesn't erase history or our knowledge
of those people but it does send a
message that we are ready to say this
was wrong these individuals should not
be honored the way they are things
change
statues go up and come down all the time
as global sentiment changes what we're
seeing now is an awakening of national
and even global consciousness that has
been a long time coming if it makes you
uncomfortable that's a
okay just think about why that is allow
yourself to be uncomfortable and listen
to voices you may have ignored in the
past history is a process and we're all
living through it the world and
especially the United States is taking
long overdue steps to grapple with the
sins of our past and work towards
building a more inclusive kinder world
if you'd like to help make a difference
in the lives of others consider
installing the tab for a cause Chrome
extension it's completely free and it
lets you contribute to things you care
about just by browsing the web which
you're already doing anyway you can help
fund new schools provide clean water
protect the environment support the
n-double-a-cp and more tab for a cause
puts a couple of small ads on each new
tab you open and then donates that money
to the charity of your choice it takes
less than 30 seconds to add the
extension to your browser and you can
start making a difference right now
install tab for a cause by visiting tab
gladly do slash second thought if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to see
more like it consider subscribing to
stay up to date with my latest episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down and if you really want to
help support my channel I recently
started a patreon which you can find at
patreon.com slash second thought you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen thanks
for watching and I'll see you next week